مباشره الى هذه الصور لاستقبال الملك
تشيلسي في برلين في اول زياره خارجيه له
وطبعا الرئيس الالماني فرانك فالتر هو من
يستقبل الملك
تشيلسي في العاصمه
الالمانيه برلين في اول زياره خارجيه
للملك تشارلز اذا وصل الملك البريطاني
الملك تشارلز الى وجهته الخارجيه الاولى
الى العاصمه الالمانيه برلين وكما تابعنا
قبل قليل بدات هذه الزياره باستقبال الملك
تشارلز من قبل
فرانك فالتر الرئيس الالماني
اذا اول زياره خارجيه
له طبعا كان قد تاخر ثلاثه ايام عن الموعد
المقرر وعلى بعد 885 كيلو مترا شمال الشرق
الدوله التي كان يرغب ان تكون اولى وجهاته
كملك اذا كان طبعا يود ان تكون هذه الوجهه
هي باريس
اهداف الزياره ايضا كما وصفت تظل بانها
تعزيز للعلاقات البريطانيه مع اوروبا
واظهار قدره المملكه المتحده في
يعني هذه المعركه التي توصف بانها معركه
الكسب في القاره اذا هذه صور
نتابعها مباشره لوصول الملك تشيلسي الى
العاصمه الالمانيه برلين في اول زياره
خارجيه له